walk him to this video coverage for the
round 13 game of the candidates
tournament between former World Champion
Randy makram league and veselin topalov
and yeah I guess this is some case of a
game where for both players the the
tournament standings is not important
anymore they both have to be honest just
screwed up so much earlier that they
don't have any any chance and while
still it's nice to win a bit of more
money if you finish one place higher or
whatever but for both of them only first
place was the big girl and they have
failed in this this aspect pretty pretty
clearly the pile of being on a minus 2
score being on last place is it minus 2
he's on minus 1 i'm sorry i'm sorry i
miscalculated that he had beaten Sevilla
I'm sorry malice wall and chronic also
being on a minus 1 score after yet lost
those two terrible games against
kayaking and swollen but in the first
part of the tournament tupolev had one
is his game um against against scrum
lick in a very brutal fashion and I'm
very very sure that crumbling wants to
win this game whatever happened before
because of their personal history there
is certainly for both players the wish
to win the game very much and was the
way it was very clear that this wouldn't
be a doll draw so let's see what happens
so we play a perfectly normal opening
the pool of playing the the semi Slav
already showing that he is not averse to
a sharp fight chronic plays Bishop g5
here I think normally plays that move he
he also has played of course III they
all did that at some point this for
instant was played by Kramnik in the in
the rapids play off of the world
championship match that those two had
analyst
2006 but also crumbling is a big expert
on the Bishop g5 line here which may
lead to the boot Vinick after the
capture or age 60 God Moscow variation
they both have played this position with
both sides numerous times so the big
question is here to take or not to take
for a number of years the move Bishop h4
was all the rage giving up a pawn after
this like him keep his pawn and this is
of course a very murky line very
complicated stuff and probably one of
the very rare lines in in all in all of
chess where black can actually combine
the moves b5 and g5 without being
outright terrible yeah some somewhere I
once read the centered so that the
combination of those two moves should
always lead to the loss of the game
which is quite a funny statement but
there is some there's some truth to that
it's very often a good idea good idea to
to loosen your position on both flanks
in fact in a recent game that I played
in an entirely different situation i
also had played b5 and g5 and i was
immediately in trouble after that so
can't be careful with those pawns okay
this didn't happen Kramnik took on f6
Queen f6 and III which is of course a
much more strategically inclined way to
play but of course a very healthy
approach white is just taking on f6
which will cost black some time the
Queen has already moved here and black
will also need a bit of time to get his
pieces developed on the other hand black
of course has the bishop pair at the
moment the bishops are not terribly
great especially
the c8 bishop the steady problem of the
Queens gambit declined in all kinds of
forms you need to get this Bishop into
the game yeah this is a very interesting
strategic own battle between central
control and development on Whiteside
yeah what has good play in the center
and blacks bishops g6 now played here
here you can debate what is like the
most precise move order the general
approach with g6 and Bishop to d7 as
nowadays considered to be the the main
line in this setup it's on g7 simply for
one reason black wants to play at some
point see 5 or a 5 and in both cases the
bishop is well positioned on g7 it
supports a 5 directly and also of course
tries to do something against the
default born in case of c 5s coming
later we actually get a quite uncommon
position now because kramnik now place
the directive 95 this can actually be um
seen as a kind of refutation attempt of
black set up because quite often black
is playing an early night to d7 in this
line which pretty much rules out any 95
moves so 95 is trying to somewhat drf to
refute is a bit much but tries to punish
this omission from the black side but it
does not seem that this should lead to
any a sort of big problem for black okay
95 and now c5 was played very directly
attacking on d4 it's a bit of a tricky
move because black is opening up the
center while still being a bit
undeveloped but it's in general of
course desirable to open up the position
with the two bishops we now get a
transformation in the center cd5 and see
takes d4 yeah this must be played if you
Shahir miss just e5 hanging so not on
need to take here and after this and
this yeah we must examine again what
happens if white captures he didn't do
that play droopy one but if white now
takes you go here and now you get some
problems in the center this Bishop is
making itself oops making itself felt
yeah d 5 is just hanging in the night is
saying if you're retreated going to take
here and with the center completely
cleared this will be a very strong piece
on g7 bishops will rule yeah you can try
to protect here but you will always get
some problem taking us just not doing
much crumb liquor improved this position
first rookie won and now played to
Bishop b5 yeah this is a bit of a
strange looking move but it has two
ideas it looks at those squares where
black mighty developed the night so it
just prevents the night development and
it also might be transferred to be three
to intensify the pressure on d5 what we
got here is a very typical paw
information in them center the so-called
ram information which in German nerve is
the video of formation quite quite
strange to have some some animal
mentioned in relation to a bone
structure but it's supposed to be like
22 of those animals bullying butting the
heads together those pawns quite quite a
funny way to tell her to describe things
but okay the struggle very often is
about putting pressure on those parts
and getting the more active pieces
blacks a problem in this respect is this
Bishop it's not a very great piece it
just always just defending d5 but black
has two bishops so it's probably a
that is somewhere between a little bit
more comfortable for wide and equal to
pi love played rock d8 covering d5 and
now a six Bishop a form and rook to d6
route to the six is a bit of a
strange-looking move the problem
whatever is how do you ever get your
pieces out it's a not so easy to to to
save how to do that I don't think this
is really bad route 26 kramnik now plays
an interesting with the move Queen to be
three here in this position queen bee
three is of course move with some
technical ideas the first idea that you
have in this position at least I thought
is be five isn't this just wrapping the
bishop where is it going yeah White has
a tactical response you can play Queen
to a three but the funny thing is that
this actually was a playable line for
black at first you think black is in
trouble now this rook is attacked and
there's also Bishop takes b5 threatened
but the fun thing is Queen d8 is a play
will move Bishop takes a be Queen takes
and now look a six and Ruby six is quite
amazingly he drove by repetition it's
quite a quite a funny line and
interesting I'm really not sure if to
paula fear if they if the part of solve
this line and avoided it because he
wanted to maybe try to win the game or
if he if you didn't see it because you
can argue that if you it'd probably be
five is the is the it's the right move
from a theoretical point of view I mean
not like in a theory book but just if
you just say what is the best move is
probably be five with this drawing line
you played b6 to keep the game going all
right so chrome Nick and did some
regrouping using this small tactical
trick to attack the rook
yeah between switched over to the to the
King side yeah how to assess the
position i don't i don't really know to
be honest i think it's somewhere between
equivalent a little bit more comfortable
for white because what maybe has the
somewhat easier a way to continue we can
push on the King side for example of a
black it's slightly disorganized it's
not it's not a huge problem but i would
say that White's plays a bit easier um
this felt rather logical to me white
pushing here on the kingside black must
play g5 and white attack there they both
really wanted to yeah to play as some
ambitious as possible and this and this
type of position I guess this is such a
grudge match that they they don't wanter
want an easy life okay Queen g7 and rook
everyone yeah this is of course trying
to push the f porn so black ISM doing
that first hope to c 6 and with 93 white
controlled both these critical squares
yeah f5 this is maybe not strictly
necessary in but but not a bad move it
also opens up sorry the diagonal towards
the d4 pawn and now Kramnik decides to
to take on g5 probably am what you
should do nevertheless but this is some
real interation out of the position
black cam check needs to accept the
Queen trade and now we took on f5 so we
get get a tactical sequence now quite
interesting Bishop f5
and night x yeah of course black cannot
take here because she has a check young
you must take here first and now white
inserted this intermediate capture on c6
group takes an ITEX f5 and this is a
very a very sharp end game position now
with the white having two nights against
two bishops this normally spelled
trouble as two bishops are almost always
better than two nights but of course
it's an opposition specific and here
black has the immediate counter play
with the rook this is also a big
difference rooks on the board just mean
that the coordination of the pieces us
is is even more important night en and
rook takes on be too so he got this this
pawn bag yeah here it's all depended on
one precise calculation of lines in
check at this position here um T'Pol off
gets into slide trouble because he takes
this decision he took the session to
take the the King to f7 which looks
perfectly normal but it seems that King
g7 was the somewhat better move after 95
there is the move Bishop to b6 attacking
this night and if the night moves 34
this Bishop b6 which is a slightly
computer Ashline I admit that but it is
there and would have been better than
the game in the game after this King f7
white could could capture here and after
Bishop to c6 check and this cheque y
term has this attack now on the bishop
and also got this defense in this now
gets a bit tricky for black
played Bishop g7 and 92 f 5 now you see
that white has coordinated coordinated
nicely Bishop 2 h8 and age 6 this is of
course lights on important pawn yeah
it's white cruising to victory it looks
like that but check there's still some
work to be done d5 check went back and
now night g3 yeah this tries to activate
the rook pause and tries to win a temp
or no on the the bishop one near fall we
should be Sally and now we entered with
the rook we come to a critical position
quite soon check I was a bit too quick
I'm sorry he had this position this
position black absolutely needs to take
on f5 but she didn't do he played them
needs to take and then probably using
the King to stop the edge porn this rook
t2 was in fact in fact a substantial
mistake 19 g7 check was played by
Kramnik King to e7 check and now d6
check yeah this was some an important in
important point maybe miss by 2 paulo
and yeah he now has to take if you go
here there is this check and well then
you need to take it's just delaying
things rook f8 and now a before plate
yeah the problem is that this is
basically a trap bishop and if black
captures on g7 and takes here there is
no way to to stop the porn really as
it's very unlucky that check your right
into this kind of thing and in addition
there is also a key for which also
happens
after check you should to age them
simply I'm simply not not great yeah
this is what's to pile of plate and
chrome Nicky took the bishop of course
and now be three ok so the beep on is a
black flecks absolutely final hope and
quite fitting for the tournament that
that chrome Nick also has he's now
playing a really big mistake but a
mistake that is probably not so apparent
if you don't know if you if you don't
check it with the computer the computer
immediately points this out but it's not
it's not easy to to see really he played
the setlist check which looks perfectly
normal as it blocks this diagonal and we
passed the age porn yeah to move forward
um the problem with this move will glued
the camera parent but what he needed to
do was to play whoopty a time just want
to show this uh this winning Lion King
somewhere and then 94 well he answer
it's running into some sort of fork you
can also go to c6 it's not much of a
difference there i'm playing age 7 and
this is a very obvious win the problem
is i think that that Kramnik thought
that both moves win and he went to this
the problem is however now T'Pol off
could have saved the game well could
have implies that he didn't here if
black plays king c7 he will draw as
simple as that it's a stone cold raw
because the beep on is just it's just
too much why can't push h7 and after be
too wide can even promote with the check
chant like with this
check but this is just coming or let's
say white needs to force a perpetual
check now sb1 queen acer is coming you
can you can try check the 96 and moves
like that but check even this is not
check it's not leading to anything it's
even black with the porn but it's a it's
just a just a tall not much not much
else I wonder something else that's even
this move jan is getting the getting the
piece yeah it's really it's really it's
really amazing King c7 would have grown
but the pile of took on a five check
after which night x + 5 and now aged 7
is is easily winning it's a quite quite
remarkable that he had mister mister
save be to check and now check
everything's in order for why it's
because there is no bishop anymore on d3
that can actually support the promotion
after this and queen age 7 check to pile
of resigned so I'm quite a dramatic
finish to this game it was really very
complicated but I must admit that I had
a game myself today of about six hours
playing time and I didn't find the time
to do a very thorough analysis of this
game I was mostly pointing out some
decisive moments um yeah okay from nixle
will consider this tournament to be a
real real disaster but he got some
summary wrench in this game not without
some luck at the end well T'Pol of could
have saved it just a couple of moves
before them and and get Apollo firm with
these losses getting back to a minus to
score so we will finish this tournament
with a negative score
certainly had had hopes to to win this
whole event so he will be very
disappointed anyway alright thanks for
watching this game